shows like NCIS are often a great
showcase for agan actors a guess spot
doesn't require a significant time
commitment but the roles are usually
more meaty than a quick appearance on a
sitcom or soap opera NCIS in particular
seems to do a great job at casting
longtime Veterans of the business and
helping them get one last great role
before they retire or pass away Nina fch
got that chance when she played Victoria
Mard in two episodes of NCIS one in
season 2 and again in season 3 as a
mother of Donald ducky Mard botch got to
play an important character in the
show's Cannon it was one of her last
ever appearances helping to cap a career
that stretched all the way back to the
1940s her notable credits include iconic
films such as the Ten Commandments and
An American in Paris in classic
television shows including gunm smoke
Bonanza and Murder She Wrote The New
York Times reported that fotch died in
2008 at the age of 84 calling her an
actress in sophisticated roles